Da.
Când te uiți la capabilitățile de azi, cred că e
și o întrebare foarte importantă să spui: ei bine,
care e foaia de parcurs, adică cu cât
mai bune sunt aceste sisteme
și cu cât mai complexe
vor fi circuit-urile pe care le vom putea executa
și pentru asta am dezvoltat o metrică foarte importantă
numită quantum volume
uneori s-ar putea să citești sau să auzi în presa populară
numărul de qubit-uri, știi
ca măsură a progresului
îți spun direct că
doar numărul de qubit-uri din mașină nu e o
măsură bună a progresului
progresul trebuie măsurat prin
nivelul de complexitate al circuit-ului pe care îl poți executa
qubit-urile și aceste mașini bune nu sunt perfecte azi
și au erori introduse de cuplarea
sistemului cu lumea exterioară
tocmai puterea acestor qubit-uri,
entanglement-ul și acele proprietăți,
le face totodată și puternice
și delicate față de interferența
și conexiunea cu lumea exterioară
deci trebuie să reduci rata de erori
în timp ce crești numărul de qubit-uri
asta e ceea ce e ilustrat aici
ce vrei cu adevărat să faci e să te miști pe diagonală
iar quantum volume e o măsură care incorporează
ambele acele metrici și câteva considerații suplimentare cheie